la 5g chinoise ressemble à s'y méprendre
au cheval de troie faut-il que lui
ouvrions nos portes
la commission européenne doit présenter
sous 15 jours
une position concertée à propos de la
cyber sécurité des réseaux 5 g monsieur
le ministre quelle sera la position de
la france sur ce sujet ce matin avait
lieu d'ailleurs un moment très important
un moment où s'agissant de rénover le
multilatéralisme qui vous le savez
parfois battus en brèche par certaines
puissances et bien l'europe était
présente à travers le président de la
commission européenne à travers la
chancelière merkel le président de la
république et mène macron aux côtés du
président chi pour affirmer un certain
nombre est bien d'engagement pour que ce
multilatéralisme soit toujours vivace
tout cela se fait dans un moment où
l'europe elle même est bien est en train
de revoir un certain nombre de ses
cadres d'intervention et de ses cadres
tout simplement de coopération notamment
en matière commerciale en matière
économique
il s'agit il s'agit s'agissant de nos
industries stratégiques nos industries
sensibles de nous doter d'un cadre
protecteur sans discrimination mais
d'ailleurs nos amis chinois font de même
il est important et bien de s'engager
également cette voie là mais aujourd'hui
c'est la coopération qui s'est exprimé
et c'est heureux monsieur bériault il
vous reste en seconde pour la réplique
bah écoutez j'ai pas reprendre la
question parce que j'ai pas eu de
réponse j'aurais vraiment aux yeux
j'aurais souhaité avoir une réponse sur
la question derouet et surtout sur
toutes les questions qui touchent nos
réseaux informatiques et notre
dépendance de plus en plus forte dans
des domaines où la stratégie a aussi sa
place et c'est là à mon avis sur le plan
européen à une question que nous devons
traiter de manière sérieuse merci
quelle n'a pas été mon étonnement en
lisant les propositions du parti
majoritaire et de vos ministres avec
toujours plus de taxes et d'impôts
augmentation des droits de succession
taxation des plus values sur les
résidences principales
retour de la taxe carbone alors monsieur
le premier ministre
quand allez vous enfin comprendre qu'il
faut sortir de cette addiction à l'impôt
pouvez vous vous engagez aujourd'hui à
ne crée ni augmenter aucun impôt ne
partageons point de vue qu'avec impôts
il faut utiliser un verbe les baisser il
est vrai monsieur le sénateur que pour
baisser les impôts il faut baisser la
dépense et de ce point de vue et de ce
point de vue il ya beaucoup de croyants
mais peu de pratiquants puisque lorsque
nous proposons de baisser la dépense et
singulièrement à la majorité sénatoriale
dans le détail nous avons quelques
quiproquos
je n'ai pas attendu monsieur le sénateur
de la part du chef de votre partie des
propositions claires de baisse de la
dépense publique bien au contraire
alors oui notre pays doit baisser encore
plus ses impôts c'est ce que nous
faisons sur l'impôt sur les sociétés sur
la taxe sur l'habitation évidemment sur
tout un taux qui demain pourraient
grever notre économie le premier travail
sur les impôts de production et nous
vous demandons s'il vous plaît de faire
une revue de détail
dites-nous si c'est possible là où vous
souhaitez vous baisser la dépense
publique je vous remercie
le général de gaulle disait quand je me
regarde je me désole mais quand je me
compare je me console
si la première partie de sa phrase
relate bien la situation de la france la
deuxième partie absolument pas allons
monsieur le premier ministre si vous
voulez enfin vous consoler agissez
agissez vite fait des économies et
arrêter de penser qu'à puiser dans la
bourse des français
[Musique]